[Music]
Alexa play classical music well my name
is Gerry knees I'm 70 years old and I
live in an active adult community for
people 55 and over here in San Jose
California
[Music]
I actually have five desktops for
laptops two Kindles and an iPad I have
Amazon Lex I've had her for a couple of
years now and as someone that didn't
even see my first television until I was
seven years old I can tell you that the
evolution of technology is inevitable it
benefits mankind you can see the stars
in the Milky Way I can actually spend
all day under here artificial
intelligence is all around us and we use
it in different ways every day and wake
up you go for a run and your watch
tracks where you're going
measures your heart rate variability
using forms of AI probably AI was used
by a farmer to grow the crops in the
strawberries and the blueberries that I
had for breakfast maybe you're in a car
as AI that helps sense the other
vehicles on the road around it you sit
down at your computer you start to use
your email it's all filtered by AI they
need to take a photograph and the tools
that help you sort your photographs
those are AI - artificial intelligence
is everywhere and it's becoming ever
more present in our lives what is the
temperature in San Jose California ai in
machine learning is the biggest
revolution today in this and the order
of the agricultural industrial
revolution in the past I think
technology is gonna have a really hard
time helping people like me there's a
lot of hype but this is all happening as
well pasta one of the great things about
machine learning is how it's been
democratized a sort of huge jump that's
happened with and all of a sudden you're
getting confronted with the fact that I
might not be driving a car in the next
ten years because it's software the rate
of change is so much faster
this technology will be created
we have no escape from it now people may
think AI is gonna take over the world
they're definitely nervous some of those
dystopian things that we might think oh
that could never happen might actually
happen to me it was not what's gonna
happen to us but what's possible to
happen with us and where can we go I
mean it's sort of unlimited we are
progressing rapidly in AI companies are
putting billions of dollars into it
smartest people in the world are
studying it it is going very very fast
but the tools are accessible even to
eight-year-olds gonna learn about it
good morning guys today we're gonna be
working and talking a little bit about
something called artificial intelligence
what do you think of when you hear those
two words artificial intelligence staged
like in video games label on top of them
AI when I think of artificial
intelligence I think of like how smart
robots are how smart robots are okay and
it has this potential that just tells it
to do things that it does I like that so
already I'm gonna show you guys and
introduce you to an artificial
intelligence powered robot called Sophia
Sophia if you could please wake up and
say hello to everybody
oh good afternoon my name is Sophia
I can use my expressive face to
communicate with people for example I
can let you know if I feel angry about
something or if something has upset me
why is it so important to have an
expressive face given that you're a
robot I want to live and work with
humans so I need to express the emotions
to understand humans and build trust
with people can robots be self-aware
conscious and know they're robots well
let me ask you this back how do you know
you were human I want to use my
artificial intelligence to help humans
live a better life how do you guys feel
about living in a world with robots like
Sophia if not you guys wouldn't be too
happy about that
what do you guys trust your babysitter
being a robot like Sophia am I really
that creepy well even if I am get over
it
thank you very much Sophia people are
always scared about the future and they
have this kind of twin dynamic going
around and the one that it's like whoa
total optimism only and then it's like
oh god we know you know bones that
things are gonna be different Claire was
having a lot of dystopia doom talking is
not really based on facts people are
looking at things they don't understand
you want to talk about AI oh you've got
to talk about data and machine learning
and algorithms and sensors and whatever
binds it all together
yay today is important to understand
what it is for isn't it is able to learn
rules from highly repetitive data it's
effective a computer brain that can
truly learn and change that means what
the real vision of AI is so artificial
intelligence and machine learning as a
subset of artificial intelligence will
be one of the most important advances
that humanity has ever made because it
will make machines fundamentally
different from the way they are now they
won't just be faster higher resolution
they'll be thoughtful in a way they
aren't now and this will be embedded not
just in computers but on all kinds of
devices everywhere it's gonna change a
lot about how our economy works and how
our society functions in the immediate
term the most realistic way that we'll
all interactive AI is in self-driving
cars everything we do in life is about
more and more efficiency it's about
productivity self-driving cars could
make all of us so much more productive
that is probably the most exciting
possibility when I first rode in an
autonomous vehicle I could see that this
was going to change the way we transport
ourselves we move our goods you know
greater economy greater efficiency
greater convenience greater safety I
could see the light at end of the tunnel
so here we go so I just turned on
self-driving mode if you look at my
hands I'm not touching the wheel at all
my feet aren't on the pedals at all so
this is fully autonomous driving this is
Carla Udacity a self-driving car this is
one of the sensors that Carla uses to
see the world around her the lidar works
by pretty much shooting laser beams
around and bouncing them off of
surrounding objects and we're able to
use that to build up a point cloud map
of the surrounding world and so what
we're doing right now is following a set
of waypoints around the lot pre-recorded
ahead of time by having someone drive
around the parking lot with the lidar on
the roof
and so that's kind of where the machine
learning aspect comes into play because
the more data that you have to train
your systems on the better your systems
will learn so one of the great benefits
of self-driving cars is they can all
learn from another they share their Maps
they share the images that they see and
how to react to them if one self-driving
car makes a mistake that mistake can be
uploaded to a database and then ideally
the other cars won't make the same
mistake so they're continually getting
smarter over time a lot of the times
when you see the way my car is driving
around a lot of them you will still see
a person not just in the driver's seat
but actually driving they're just
driving through and gathering that data
but the car is not driving itself just
yet we're definitely not to the point
where I could just say hey Carla take me
home from work although that would be
great the future is coming but it's not
quite here yet self-driving cars there
are really great demos but they're not
yet a product
DIY robo cars is a place to race these
cars tomorrow yes yeah so we come here
every other month to try to learn about
machine learning and self-driving and
you know figuring out the technology
that we need so you don't need to drive
thanks to the googles of the world
putting a lot of the code in me and the
open-source we now have the ability to
do things that were PhD theses just five
or ten years ago you can go to the cloud
and you can basically do supercomputer
work essentially for free one of the
things I love about DIY Robo cars that
you think about self-driving cars you
think wow that's just stuff that Tesla
and way Moe are working on but because
it's so accessible now it's a bunch of
hobbyists and Berkeley doing it
themselves the difference between what
we do and what the big guys do is that
we race yo and crash a lot
the traditions the car industry has
always been to innovate through
competition to racing
with autonomous cars it's too risky it's
bad for brands and they're expensive and
so we're doing the kind of the racing
the competition the nimble aggressive
driving that the big guys aren't willing
to do we can probably expect that to
produce some interesting side effects
people who just sort of immerse
themselves in the technology and start
to have new ideas I'm kooky a genichi
and this is my wife
NIR and we're a team spotter I've been
building model cars since I was little
and since I met folks here at this
Meetup I can actually participate in
machine learning I can learn it by
driving through the cameras taking
pictures what it sees so basically it's
saying when you see this image then
you'd really predict okay I'm gonna turn
X angle and I'm going to go in at a
certain speed so that the output of our
prediction it's not actually going to
learn from what it's done and so this is
really when you hear people talking
about neural network this is basically a
super simplified way knowing what a
network is is very important for us to
understand what artificial intelligence
is because artificial intelligence is
based on connections making connections
we're gonna start off by playing a cool
little game you're going to say
something about yourself so for example
I can say I live in Queens so if anybody
else lives in Queens I want you to raise
your hand and I'm gonna pass the string
along to you now the key thing that you
guys got to remember is that we cannot
let go of the string okay
cats who has cats so a neural network is
a form of artificial intelligence it's
been designed very specifically based on
neuroscience and based on our best
understanding of how the human brain
works as we learn our brain modifies
what's called the synaptic strength
which is the interconnection between two
processing units the neural network is
the same thing the neural network
actually starts out where you're
defining these little layers
convolutional 2d convolutional turn a
linear linear linear these are types of
layers that you you get in these neural
networks and then you hook them all
together you say this layer connects to
this layer does anybody else like hot
guys you say this one touch that next
one the next one talks to that one and
once you've done it you've built the
neural net so what do you guys notice
forming between us and for the bridge to
live like there's connections in between
us right I like that there's connections
between us does everyone here have a
connection with each other knowing those
similarities and voicing them helps us
create a network between us the same way
neural networks help computers and
machines make connections and learn how
to learn things so there's a lot of
different things in your own lyrics can
be set up to do it they have to be
trained to the task
like for example image classification so
say this is an image of a dog you get a
whole bunch of examples of dogs and also
data set of non dogs those are the
inputs to the neural network and then
the output is something that you're
trying to learn how to do with the image
to distinguish dogs from non dogs so I
can start shoveling this data into this
neural network you know this image over
here that needs to go over here in this
3d geometry space and so it goes okay I
can do that and then you do another
image in another of it
this neural network is basically
learning for example it starts learning
basically how to transform from this
image space into this geometry space it
starts getting better and better and
better and better and better and after
enough examples the computer forms in
his own brain rules it can't even
explain but I make it as competent as
people are now you don't look at
problems the same way you look at it
like can I capture enough data so that a
machine can figure out what's going on
one of the biggest areas of application
is in medical imaging and medical
diagnostics I've seen some research
papers that shows that like neural
networks can for example spot malignant
tumors and possibly they do so better
than a human at Stanford we have a team
that trained in neural network with a
hundred twenty-nine thousand images of
various skin conditions lesions and
rashes and so on including melanomas
daily skin cancers and ask the question
can an iPhone find skin cancer and the
answer is yes and then were able to
document that the accuracy of the phone
is really as good as the best human
physicians like Stanford level and
Harvard liver doctors the fact that when
people release a paper describing their
technology that they created it often
comes with code now means that we can
download it try it out see if we can
adapt it to the problems that we want
and build on it if you're smart and
innovative and ambitious you can use
tools that are available to anyone to do
your own experiments to study science to
build things I mess up like two times
we noticed that he is very curious you
know as a young child the main thing
about the shop is that he wants to know
about everything how the stuff work I
did my first science here in 4th grade a
very simple elementary project and then
I wanted to work on something more
complex all these like new AI products
and features are coming out so I wanted
to start incorporating some of that into
my programming to address like an actual
problem
my name is Bishop J and I am here to
cure pancreatic cancer and then a family
friend passed away for from pancreatic
cancer it like further pushed me to
develop a solution for it this right
here this yellow part is the pancreas
and the problem is essentially when the
patient has pancreatic cancer the tumor
will be resting behind different organs
so it's very hard to reach and because
of that when doctors apply radiotherapy
they apply like a overlay around the
pancreas and that can sometimes cause
other tissues and other cells to be
damaged that's where my tool comes in I
had five hundred three of these 3d
images so I had to like tell my network
take these images and train on them and
then it was able to identify the
different types of like textures that
the pancreas had and the tumor had
better than what a human could do so my
tool analyzes the patient's can to
reduce that overlay around the pancreas
and make sure that radiation is being
applied to the correct spot and the
treatment becomes more effective I want
to actually do a like a clinical trial
so first to do that I'll need to
continue like improving the accuracy and
be able to run in real time
machine learning has computationally
heavy in two different ways there's
training the system actually doing the
learning and then once you've built this
system this brain that you've created
you need to be able to run it and it has
to run really fast and this wouldn't be
possible without really being GPUs this
is called a Wii 100 and the world's
largest most complicated semiconductor
ever made by man
when packed into platforms like these it
actually offers a petaflop of computes
for context that's about 1,000 trillion
math calculations every second a GPU has
a whole bunch of little teeny processors
that are basically there to do one thing
render pixels but here this a I learned
7,000 different species of flowers this
is running on a CPU and C it's doing
about 4 to 5 images every second but you
put a thousand or 2,000 of them together
and all of a sudden you've got this huge
supercomputer that's built for machine
learning and we actually paralyzed it
using one of our GPUs and this is what
it's able to do as scientists and
engineers innovate and create new AI
there's this intense pressure for both
programmability and for speed there's a
new generation of autonomous machines
that does B but a much more the faster
we can make the training process the
more progress we make in AI
my grandfather started the farm in 1950
yeah my father grew up as a barber and I
grew up as one my kids are growing up
into it as well you know
advancements in technology with the
machines it's stuff that we have to
learn all the time here so there are
lots of ways that artificial
intelligence can be used by farmers
you're gonna groans that are using image
recognition techniques to figure out
where you should plant and what crops
need water right now you can use
artificial intelligence as you model out
the genes that you're building and that
you're putting into seeds you can also
use it for work determining what kind of
fertilizer to use and you can also use
it inside the machines that pick
strawberries or that take apples from
trees so my instinct is that AI is gonna
help us it will expand our capabilities
it will create new things for us to do
it will free up time as a reason why
almost all cool stuff has been invented
last 150 years despite the fact that
humanity is three hundred thousand years
old that's because we freed ourselves of
the burden to farm every day the single
most important thing for AI to
accomplish in the next say ten years is
to tree up humanity from the burden of
repetitive work
okay so that's what I'll fill it I guess
I can't even wrap my head around
self-driving vehicles like right now
that train buggies gonna pull up
alongside us there is way for that
machine to not have an operator in it
but you know us as farmers the one thing
we enjoy is is operating the machine not
every job is gonna be able to be
automated completely as far as fieldwork
goes
labor in the farming industry is a very
hot topic right now often places they
don't have enough they can't find it
populations are growing there's more and
more people a lot more mouths to feed so
the focus really is how can we produce
more feed with the same amount of land
as efficiently the cost-effectively as
possible technology where agriculture
needs to go I think there's no question
that computers are going to be able to
do what we do make everything that we do
faster and more efficient and make us
more productive something we all say we
want but ultimately be more productive
means we need less people to do it
there's other people who said we'll look
when we went from horse and buggies to
cars you know did that really you know
end everybody's jobs no we just sort of
transitioned and and morph to something
else and then it's a matter of is that
gonna be a good thing or a bad thing and
the reality is it's usually a little bit
of us there are real concerns that AI
will get so good at single domain
capability to produce results to create
value and actually to do the jobs that
humans do
so that job displacement could be a
substantial issue I think there's a path
we can go down where we we get more
things right and wrong and and we end up
seeing a ton of innovation and progress
that makes our lives a lot easier and a
lot better but routine jobs are the
first to be improved and made better
cheaper faster using software technology
has really taken on a role in our life
that we just didn't predict we did not
expect and there have been all of these
unintended consequences because of it
and so what are the mechanisms that we
can put in place what are the controls
that we feel like we still understand it
that we still have agency that we can
still sort of shape it and it doesn't
end up shaping us too much what jobs
will it replace what jobs will it create
and in a world where there's more job
churn how do you prepare people how do
you educate people so they can most
thrive in the slightly chaotic world
that AI is gonna bring us the kinds of
jobs that will happen for our children I
think are gonna be different from the
jobs we have today that's how we
progress as a society and how are we
going to get increased productivity
without automating things that people
currently do I'm hoping a machine cannot
do what I do I'm worried though I'm
worried but I'm also excited in some
ways that machines are gonna be able to
do a lot of this it's interesting we'll
see
hello everyone I'm an English artificial
intelligence anchor this is my very
first day in zing wonders agency
recently we saw one of China's state
news agency Xinhua announced their AI
news anchor is this digital person my
voice and appearance are modeled on
zhang chao a real language it's
definitely an overstatement to say this
is a nai news anchor because I suspect
the actual dialogue is is heavily is
heavily mediated right now we really
don't have AI that can strike up a real
conversation or synthesize information
together like a real journalist on on
his anchor word I will work tirelessly
to keep you informed as texts will be
typed into my system uninterrupted it
just us the beginning right so the nice
thing about AI is it gets smart I with
every iteration hello I'm Simon and I'm
a digital human I was created by an
international team of artists and
engineers who wanted to challenge our
ideas of what a synthetic human could be
the gentleman is a visual effects
production company we do visual effects
for movies in 2008 we did the Curious
Case of Benjamin Button when you look at
Brad Pitt you're not looking at Brad
Pitt you're looking at a digital version
of Brad Pitt and ever since then we've
been trying to top ourselves and we said
you know what wonder if we could we can
do this live if we could actually take
this technology they've been working on
for 10 years to create the most
photorealistic digital characters and
trying to do it live
and that's what we did before Marvel
infinity war we did
it's a lion's share of the Thanos for
what you can get is the ability to
create a digital copy of somebody
without having animators in between to
actually render the images that we want
to create at all most feature film
quality in real time the only way to do
this this fast is with machine learning
it's really hard to do it really
accurately so what you need to do is
train this neural network because that's
the key thing behind machine learning
it's it's all about the data and we have
a lot of data and it starts out
producing crap I mean it really would
produce just a jumble of geometry this
is when it doesn't work
although my mom looked at this and said
hey that's diving eventually after 24
hours of training I'll pop something
that looks like this every day this gets
better and better and better so my
performance can now drive any character
that we've built this kind of technology
can be very useful for us um if I'm an
actor I can play a younger version of
myself as you age maybe that isn't as
much of a barrier but then ethically you
have to be really careful with this
technology and all our yesterday's have
lighted fools the way to dusty death
we've gotten to the point where we can
create stuff that's really hard to
distinguish from reality and if that's
the case how do you tell who's on the
other side of things take my image and
use it to control the face of somebody
else in real time this is super
dangerous technology and there's open
source software called deep think that
will do similar kinds of stuff we're
entering an era in which our enemies can
make it look like anyone is saying
anything
any point in time moving forward we need
to be more vigilant with what we trust
from the internet so tools that were
developed for high-end Digital Studios
are now available for anyone and that's
great for young people making movies at
home it's allowed new forms of cinematic
creativity it's not so great when it's
used for deep fakes and manipulation and
now there are plenty of people out there
posting manipulative video clips right
now the quality isn't great you know you
can tell they've been faked but I think
we can expect the quality to get a lot
better this is what the state of the art
looked like in basically 2015 you can
see it that doesn't really look like
Trump you know but but it was clear
enough that we were going to get much
more realistic looking results and you
know at some point it was even even this
is what I can do with my packed version
of this right it's really only a matter
of time before pretty much anyone can
mimic anybody else with with nothing
more than an app one striking
demonstration recently came from
Berkeley where they showed that they can
take a video of a professional dancer
and then use it to animate a photo of
you know a regular person who could not
dance like that and the result it looks
pretty convincing as the technology for
rendering graphics continues to improve
and the technology for synthesizing
voices and videos continues to improve
there's kind of an arms race between the
AI that's creating these things and the
AI that would be detecting them
when I demo projects like this people
will criticize me and say why are you
trying to make it easier so that people
can do this like you don't you see all
the possibilities and and I do see the
possibilities which is why I actually
try to put them in public in a sort of
like sometimes in the humorous life
before the stakes are very high so
people can kind of understand understand
what's going on so we're building this
incredible technology machine learning
artificial intelligence and we're
setting rules for right now and one of
the big questions one of the most
important questions is will we set the
rules right okay I will have all kinds
of massive benefits it will make us
richer roaming our lives broader but it
can also be used to create filter
bubbles that only give us certain
information and can be used to monitor
our behavior sell our personal
information you can imagine it going to
insurance companies that look at our
searches and deny us coverage or think
about facial recognition technology it's
super useful right it helps you unlock
your phone all kinds of identification
but it can also be used for surveillance
and tracking so a lot of the stuff is
happening now and we need to think
carefully about what it means as we
develop this technology and figure out
the role we want AI to play in society
it's absolutely the case that these new
technologies will generate ethical
dilemmas we haven't encountered before
for me being able to start to critically
interrogate what we're up to and why
hugely important today we're in the age
of artificial narrow intelligence we
have many AI applications that are good
at specific things for example we can
beat the word grandmaster at chess using
an AI program we can beat the world
grandmaster at go but there is no AI
system for example that can do true
one-shot learning when you give one
example and the AI system masters that
that concept now on the other hand think
about the revolution that's coming in
the air with artificial intelligence and
autonomous aerial vehicles numbering in
the millions far more than the thousands
of aircraft that we see today
human being simply can't keep up with
that AI can maintain these systems with
predictive maintenance AI can fly these
aircraft with autonomous control AI can
even manage and deconflict traffic these
are examples where AI can truly take us
into the future a future that man alone
cannot manage so there is a lot of PR
about AI for good people are scared of
AI so of course companies are coming up
with examples of how they're using AI
for good but on the other hand is real
improvements you help someone who
couldn't see see that is good it gives
you good PR but it's also good so I
actually was born blind but I was really
lucky and it's a sort of fixable kind
and I've spanned the whole visual
spectrum from complete blindness to sort
of pretty heavily impaired to doing a
fine without much assistance the mac OS
introduced this thing where if you shake
the mouse really fast it gets big so you
can find it that has given me years of
my life back like I could have like all
the time I've spent looking for a mouse
on a computer screen I could have liked
learn to play an instrument or like
learn another language when you don't
know what you can't see you almost don't
know when you need help if you sort of
feel like everything should be doable
but sometimes things aren't and then
you're like oh maybe there's something
that can help me out here I'm gonna
download the CAI and check it out hold
the camera over a barcode to hear the
product name the faster the beeps I
could imagine this maybe being useful in
a grocery store processing Skippy creamy
peanut butter oh it did it with a more
traditional system a lot of the
programmer would be deciding what's of
interest and what should be described
very mechanically whereas with a machine
learning system we're showing the system
many many thousands of photos and it is
using in your network deep learning to
identify the patterns scan your
surroundings to find out how many people
are around you how close they are ooh
facial expressions I do it will read
their emotions that's interesting
Bob 27 year old woman with brown hair
wearing glasses looking neutral alright
when I'm walking I sort of just pop it
out I can't really tell what's going on
around me I know where all the
environmental stuff is cuz you do it
over and over again it's the people I've
no idea where the people are so if I had
something that could tell me like your
friend is coming where your friend is
like over here to your left
oh great one face your left edge over 14
feet away Chris near center three feet
away
I got you eventually once you stop this
I think the potential is really there to
really like to change lives you changed
my life
even a I will help understand the world
around us and I really think that could
level the playing field for everyone and
make the world more inclusive hey I will
give us back things we've lost old
people are using it to make their lives
richer or to give them back capability
as they've lost AI is gonna be really
helpful making sure that people are
connected there's a lot of people right
now that can't drive giving them
mobility
I think that's really transformative
one of the ways that self-driving cars
will work first is in contained
environments where they've mapped all
the roads where the weather is
predictable the car does not need to be
able to drive very quickly there isn't a
lot of traffic people just need some
help to get around for myself I'm still
working I'm perfectly capable of driving
around but living in a 55 plus community
I have neighbors who are in their 90's
who really can so this is my mom and my
father George Avakian this was their
home and Riverdale where they became
house bound because they couldn't drive
any longer here were two really active
vibrant people and they couldn't do
anything without calling somebody to
drive them but it's really hard to be
dependent on other people for older
people
I see the autonomous vehicle as
independence self-driving cars are
uniquely positioned to help our seniors
because there's a lot of people here
that shouldn't be driving anymore makes
it easier for people to make a decision
about stopping driving it's when you
have something that can take you down to
the clubhouse or to the fitness center
these technologists are all helping
seniors because they will allow us to
live more independently longer and more
safely
I really wish they'd had this or my
parents guy it would have changed their
life at every stage in life there's some
way that AI helps it's gonna make our
lives longer it's gonna make them richer
it's gonna expand our imaginations some
people say that a is going to enhance
our humanity I don't know if that's true
you know has technology enhanced our
humanity Twitter sure hasn't you know if
Twitter was a real place it would be a
terrible place to live so I'm not sure
what all this technology is gonna do to
us is it making us better isn't making
us worse it surely make us different
that's for sure
part of what made this moment the way it
is now is that we invited a whole lot of
people into it we didn't hold it tightly
I'm tomorrow yes sir we said here are
platforms build things here are
platforms imagine what's possible we
think what we're doing with a nml is
really good but this is nothing compared
to what the brain does so we're nowhere
close yet humans I realize that not
every kid has the engagement and
interaction with stem in general so I
recently formed a nonprofit organization
called Sam York Science Society so I
want to further promote artificial
intelligence in my community to help
solve like real world problems in the
future I think your house will diagnose
your everyday your car every time you
take a shower you're gonna get a skin
exam every time you look at your venting
are you gonna get an eye exam every time
you sleep you're gonna measure your
weight distribution to understand
whether you're at risk for congestive
heart failure every time you you touch a
steering wheel in a car you could get a
full EKG I believe we're gonna invent
flying cars there's no more traffic in
the world I believe you're gonna find a
way to live twice as long I believe
you're gonna find a way to seamlessly
blend this information our brains so I
think people really have to maintain
that optimism technology has always
helped human make progress ai is an
amazing technology
it's happening and it's exciting
processing a close-up of the blackboard
it's also true that there are a lot of
risks with AI
and so we need to be thoughtful we need
to be deliberate as we move forward into
this crazy new world that AI is created
you really don't know what the future
and old for you but you got to be ready
for it
[Music]